thank you very much
andy dennis and yuri for inviting me
it's a pleasure to be here when i first
accepted the invitation
uh it was back in october and um we were
working on ebola that time and that
probably got yuri's interest
bugged up and luckily for all of us
although it continues to be a a problem
i think
things are looking much better so my
talk
uh is going to be about computational
epidemiology
uh the role of big data and pervasive
informatics
and before i go into the details i want
to acknowledge my collaborators
it's certainly not something that i've
done alone this is a
piece of work that spans over 20 years
and a number of folks
in our lab as well as folks in other
universities
and also the different funding agencies
so i want to thank them
for their support
so i have decided that
given the diversity of the audience i
will try and keep the talk at a
scientific american
level um i'm happy to take questions
during the talk if that's easy and we
can certainly discuss it at the end of
the talk
and what i thought was that i'll try and
have two
basic goals for today's lecture one is
to give you an overview of computational
epidemiology as
a as a branch in in science with an
emphasis
on computing and data science and how it
helps helps this
area i decided to do this because i
think
in the systems lab this might be a topic
that not
everybody is is well versed with and the
second
thing that i would like to illustrate
through this talk is
is this broad topic of computation for
social good
i think this is a beautiful topical area
for us as computer scientists to
contribute to the
to the larger societal good and
hopefully at the end of the talk
some of you might feel interested and
and decide to work on this topic and if
i've done that that would be a
uh that would be a success for this talk
i've also tried to have maybe a little
bit
more in terms of words on the slides and
uh i did it
just so that uh these slides are
if read by others at the later time are
as much as possible self-contained
uh so but i'll go through it slowly
luckily then we have a time till 5 30
which i was not aware of so i think we
get enough time to discuss it
so let me start first with uh just
defining some basic terms
what is epidemics epidemics is really a
situation
where the num incidents the number of
folks who are falling sick or the
incidences
that you're measuring in a community or
region is substantially higher
than what is typically observed right so
then that the
the definition itself is a relative term
so
for instance ebola is now viewed as an
epidemic because
the number of cases up until now are
very very small compared to what we have
seen so far
the term epidemiology comes from uh from
you know greek words epi and and demos
and uh basically deals with
the study uh of the distribution
determinants of health related states
and tries to find ways to control the
health problems that people face
the basic term has been applied in the
context of non-communicable diseases as
well over time
and also to things like malware
propagation in the internet so three
three things are important in this
particular setting one is
that you're talking about distributions
you're not talking about
individual health as much as
understanding population health and
that's a distinction between
epidemiology and medicine so to say
the second is your interest in causes
for why this is happening so
the determinants and finally you're
interested in application
coming up with ways to control epidemics
computational epidemiology or
mathematical epidemiology they're close
related
is a topic where you try and use
mathematical sciences and computational
sciences
to try and help epidemiologists address
their
scientific field so that's that's what
you know computational epidemiology in
short is and i'll i'll discuss
these aspects in detail so epidemics are
not new to us
um you know it's at least as
as old as as uh as the you know
history of of uh humankind in many ways
uh and there is a set of good literature
articles that have been cited and i have
some citations at the very end that you
can take a read
at but the good news is that
pandemics which is basically epidemics
at a global proportion
that happened have happened quite
periodically in history
at least for the time being seem
unlikely you know so the large
last big pandemic that happened was 1918
flew we had
other pandemics after that but that
probably was the biggest
in the last century by far probably
affected almost every country
every every region in the world
and we think that at least in the for
the time being such as such an event is
unlikely to occur
but most people would agree that we will
see a pandemic
the question is when and the thing is
that
even though we have made great strides
in terms of
finding out where the disease is
starting coming up with pharmaceutical
interventions
there are many new complicating factors
that i believe
uh make the problem of addressing or
solving this
you know controlling epidemics is uh is
a challenging one
so what what are the basic issues one is
that we are starting to live in cities
that are larger and larger
so the second thing is that cities are
getting more and more tightly packed
the density in urban regions is growing
we also have
immuno-compromised individuals many more
folks who are older and folks who
who who have you know other other other
diseases or
health health problems which basically
makes them immunocompromise and
increase the likelihood likelihood of
them catching a
new disease and finally we we have over
time
as we've started growing in terms of
population we're really
coming up to a situation at a place
where we're starting to interact more
and more with the environment in nature
we're sort of
affecting it in a larger large way and i
think ebola is an example where this
this might be playing out uh in in some
ways where the boundaries of the cities
is actually growing and we are we are
touching the habitat
uh of of uh you know
of other other other animals and species
in a manner that we have not done before
in in in such large numbers
so we want to keep that in mind and so
the the tools that we're going to try
and develop
hopefully we'll try and address these
issues i want to take an example
from ebola the work that we have been
working on and i'll tell you a little
bit more
about it uh this has been the largest
ebola outbreak
in the history uh ebola's history as we
know
started around 1970s uh sometime during
that time
but this one has affected a much larger
region three
three countries in in west africa with
sporadic cases in
nigeria that sort of went there mali
recently
but uh it used to be that central africa
was where ebola outbreaks happened but
this one moved into western africa and
and affected now at least 20 000
individuals these are detected cases
the general belief is that the number of
cases is far more than 20 000
and has so far caused 8 000 odd deaths
uh so this has got a huge uh you know
uh burden of disease uh in in terms of
uh
you know how many deaths it has caused
and how many forces it has infected
moreover the countries are actually just
overcoming a
lot you know long social
uh problem in terms of civil war that
was going on in these places so
you know not only do we have this big
outbreak it's in
countries which are relatively poor uh
and just recovering from from
earlier political and and social
problems and civil problems that they
had
and uh actually there's a very nice uh
you know
uh web page that new york times has
prepared and i have i look at it very
very often folks here might want to look
at it which actually outlines
uh you know many many issues that folks
who are epidemiologists or even
you know a citizen scientist would be
interested in reading
and the basic question that we want to
study things like you know
how many people have been infected where
is the outbreak where did it start
how do you stop it these are all
questions that we all as epidemiologists
are
you know even citizen scientists and
policy makers are interested in
addressing
and i think this website actually does a
very good job of cataloging these
questions
our goal here is to study what we call
real-time epidemic science
and this is becoming more and more
feasible over time and the basic idea is
that
you you don't want to develop tools that
are only useful during the planning
phase you know
say for instance preparing tools right
now for a future
pandemic that might happen but really
work with the policy makers and
and civil authorities and supporting
them
as the disease is breaking out in real
time now this is actually a
non-trivial problem uh i think as a
society we become better at it but i
think remains a
really big open question uh in terms of
how we
bring about uh uh you know changes
and and build tools and and get policy
makers to agree on on problems of of the
scale and size
uh and actually a very nice article in
science some time back it was an
editorial article by feinberg and and
her his colleague
about this question and they have
challenged the society to try and study
and build tools
to study you know develop tools for
epidemics
you know control in in real time so
here are some questions that we have uh
uh you know studied over
over a number of years before but in the
context of ebola we've been studying
them very actively
and to just give you some sense uh
we started working on ebola uh
approximately in uh
in june july time frame uh working very
closely with uh
you know several federal agencies
and uh it has been an experience of of a
kind for us as a lab
uh we're an academic institution but
given what was happening on the ground
uh the work has been very intense and
in some ways uh to us to uh
you know for us as modelers it's
rewarding to see whether
to try and support policy makers and i i
think at the end of the day the folks on
the ground deserve a lot of credit you
know
the models we make is is one thing but
the folks who are really on the ground
in these countries working out
really deserve all the kudos from us and
support from us so this this is actually
really small work in in terms of
what these folks are doing is very
challenging questions
so we started supporting some of the
agencies in u.s
through interagency you know
coordination meetings
and initially the goal was simply to
understand the epidemic
disease parameters you know the the rate
at which the infection is getting
you know trans you know the incubation
time of the disease
uh how the disease is getting you know
transmitted
where it might be we started in
forecasting the disease
and every week we actually give
presentations where these forecasts are
provided to the policy makers
and as my colleague has said
we are actually happy to to be proven
wrong in our forecast our initial
forecast
actually said the numbers are going to
be much higher than what
the current numbers report and i i
personally think of this as actually
very good news
and partly it's it's very hard to figure
out whether our forecasts are wrong
or whether the forecast that our group
and many other groups
did really galvanize this
community to change certain habits
that might have cut down on the disease
progression and this is something andy
said in his in
introduction where people are very
important elements of this unlike
physical system where you can really
deterministically say
where the moon is going to be you know
in terms of its its position uh
people adapt when they perceive diseases
and that's fundamentally a problem in
social systems
and and things like epidemics so we did
forecasting
site forecasting problems we then
studied
um in september time frame
questions related to assessing the the
chance of the disease coming to u.s
you might have heard of the news on the
tv that time and
and news outlets about uh you know cases
that came to us
and luckily things things worked out and
it was
it was very clear as modelers that
unless we did something really stupid
this is not going to
you know spread in a way that has spread
in in liberia at that time
we have far far well coordinated
system in in place we then studied uh
efficiently allocating pharmaceuticals
now there's no vaccine for ebola right
now but they're in the process there are
some
trials ongoing right now we expect
vaccines to come out sometime this year
initially the thought was that will be
very soon but i think it has been
delayed some
we do expect vaccines to come out the
current number
you know trials which are very limited
suggest that
they might be efficacious so we studied
how vaccines could be allocated
uh how many would might be required uh
you know where should they be provided
and questions of that sort another
question we studied
uh when we were working with the
agencies
was to allocate uh
you know resources in a very particular
setting which is a which is actually
a operations research question which is
to do with placing emergency treatment
units so
as you know us decided to place between
10 and 20 emergency treatment units
uh the size and their scope was not
clear early on
and we did a study to to to at least
provide guidance in what what sort of
treatment units
would be most useful where would they be
placed what sort of benefits you would
get
uh some of the results were then taken
in
and the questions are actually
non-trivial right for instance
you might actually intuitively feel like
placing a treatment unit
where the disease burden is very high at
this moment
but by the time the treatment unit gets
in place uh
the disease might have moved on to some
other place so
it's not obvious where to place these
units now if you might you might place
it in a remote place where there's no
disease
uh breakout at that point of time
uh from a social standpoint it is not a
policy that goes very well to see
something that is sitting there with
nobody using it so it's actually an
interesting operations research question
there will be now discussions about
placing these units
in a manner they call you know treatment
units in the box so they want to build
smaller units potentially
that can be moved as they see the
disease moving through the place now
this is not a straightforward matter
because you know
dismantle get the place working is a
non-trivial issue but something to be
considered
we've been studying uh you know need for
protective
gear you know face masks gloves and
other things
we've also studied the use of twitter in
assessing the public moods and
sentiments we had done another project
before for flu which is very successful
in using twitter data
in in the us and latin american
countries but we found out that
you know twitter is not used in in these
countries
at a level that we would have uh
you know wanted and as a result the
signal is rather weak
uh to to make to use twitter that
effectively at least at this point of
time
and finally we we have studied the
potential spread of ebola
into latin american countries because
one of the conjectures or
the thought was that you know
ebola would spread into latin american
countries and through migrations
and people moving into us you might
actually get a different route of
of this disease coming into us so we
wanted to study what the chances of such
a
event happening were so you can see that
these these questions are are
very diverse requires a diverse team uh
we have
over 70 folks in our lab and
the questions really are posed almost
every week on a tuesday after our
meeting is done
and they want answers reasonably quickly
and as a as a as an academician this is
actually an interesting exercise
where you try and come up with some
solution that is meaningful and then you
hopefully can refine it
but you can't you can't say you gotta
wait for three months before i come up
with an answer because that's simply
not something that that works out in a
situation like this and i think
that has been a very good learning
experience for us as a lab
to be working on a problem as an event
unfolds
and i think more and more use of such
tools uh will demand
from policy makers uh that you know we
sort of try and support them
in real time
we've set up a web page um you know the
the address is uh is there on my slides
and i think the slides are going to be
posted andy as i understand
this webpage was built out as a resource
uh for for ebola folks it has got a lot
of different
pieces of information on it we build out
you know data disease models and and
synthetic data for different countries
papers have been put there and we
continue to post new
new results and and analysis that comes
out for instance all the presentations
we have done
to our federal partners uh have been put
on these slides uh with a few little bit
of delay
uh just to make sure that the slides
slides are okay and i
encourage you folks to take a look at it
another thing that is of interest and i
told this to
yuri when i talked to him in october we
ran hackathon
we call it hack ebola in in around
october it probably was the first
ebola hackathon it was motivated
by our students wanting to contribute to
this project
and it was fairly successful we had 60
odd students participating in it
it was actually open to everybody
outside
got some projects done we also face some
challenges and challenges in terms of
getting the right teams to work together
was not straightforward one of our
students kaitlyn rivers was actually a
key contributor in fact she was the one
who coordinated this so and i
i think an exercise like this where
students from various
backgrounds come together to solve a
problem uh of of importance which i
think is is interesting and i think
uh something that we probably will do
again in spring because
i think this problem is not going to go
away anytime soon and i encourage
students here
and other places to participate when
this happens and after our
hackathon there are multiple agencies
and universities that have also
done it with varying degrees of success
again as i said depends on the problems
you pose
the the diversity of the teams that is
in place
and sometimes the problems are not
solvable in a day or two
you know you require solutions which
take a little bit of time
so this is a challenge that folks face
so let me move to now the meat of the
talk
and try to describe to you uh the
mathematics behind it and at least give
you some sense
so traditionally uh
mathematical epidemiology worked with a
class of models called mass action
compartmental models and the term mass
action means that
you assume
an interaction between populations and
individuals really are assumed to be
identical in some form
and compartmental in this case says that
there are three basic compartments the
basic models really were
motivated from chemical reactions and
people studying uh you know
physical systems and a very early
version of it not called this way
was used by daniel bernoulli when he
talked about
videolation uh for controlling smallpox
in france you know he basically is
trying to argue that
um in you know variation which is the
act of taking active smallpox from a
person who is infected and
essentially in in vaccinating somebody
is actually a good thing because
although there is a chance that somebody
is going to fall sick and
fairly severely it protects provides
herd immunity to the larger population
and he did calculations which resemble
this and there's a very nice article by
sally blauer
uh on this topic that folks here might
be interested in reading
so the simplest model has three
compartments and this is the
most elementary model this was
formalized in in early 1900s
by ross and then mckendree kermick and
mckendrick
and then by others
where in this particular setting you
have
compartments which denote susceptible
individuals
infected individuals and recovered
individuals and think of them as
really chemical reactions or molecules
uh if
for this purposes and then you talk
about uh
you know interactions between these
compartments so you say the rate of
change of folks who are
moving out of the susceptible
compartment you know the
mass essentially to the infected is
directly proportional to the
to sorry
directly proportional to the product of
the the
the size of the eye compartment the
number of infected individuals and
number of susceptible individuals right
you also have a reaction if you want to
call it an equation which tells you the
rate of change of the compartment
which are infected individuals so there
the incoming
you know particles are individuals from
s compartments are from the previous
term and then you have a rate of outflow
and the rate is gamma in this case
people recover at a rate of gamma
essentially
and then you have the last equation
which says that people recover at the
rate of
gamma and that's that's the last
equation here and that's a very
very clean simple formulation of the
problem but has been effective very very
effective for
for you know for a long time the kinds
of things you study from this
are are epidemic quantities things which
is called an epidemic curve
which tells you the time when you see
the peak of an epidemic the
the time that the length of the epidemic
uh the time when it takes off which
means you see a sudden jump in
in the curve there are formally defined
terms uh you can
look it up in in the books but this
simple model actually has been immensely
successful over the last hundred years
and reason workhorse for epidemiologists
uh
effectively was used by ross and others
to
control malaria when they're able to
effectively argue
from these models how you might want to
control malaria in the western world
it's very easy to extend add new
compartments to it
it's easy to to code if you want in in
today's matlab style codes
and i think one of the reasons this
became
powerful and useful early on was that
you could have come up with analytical
solutions in in early 1900's no
computers
and that's my conjecture of why a
different class of model that i'm going
to talk about never
really took hold and it's because people
wanted analytically closed form
solutions there was no use of coming up
with a representation theory
which could not really be solved very
well you know you wanted to
write the problem in a form that you
could come up with solutions for uh
and i think computers have changed that
this
although the models have been very
powerful they also have some weaknesses
for instance they do not represent the
heterogeneity that that is
inherent in social systems right and all
of us are not identical so this
this heterogeneity that exists in our in
urban set you know in
in in social systems is is not
represented very well
you can of course keep on breaking these
things into smaller and smaller
compartments but then
you sort of lose the appeal of the model
in the first place
the other aspect is representing of
human behavioral issues
is quite hard in this system like this
and finally
models like this it's not
straightforward to come with what i
would call
implementable strategies for
interventions and hopefully i'll be able
to give an example
in the later part of the talk so what's
an alternative approach
the alternative approach is now called
networked epidemiology
and some of you here actually have
written papers on this topic
in in different context but the basic
hypothesis here is that a better
understanding
of the social contact structure and
individual behaviors
is likely to give improved insight into
how the
disease spread or the contagion spreads
i'll use the word contagion and disease
synonymously here and allow us to cover
better response strategies right
and that's a hypothesis i hopefully i'll
be able to convince you that
this this hopefully holds and the basic
basic model is very very simple uh he's
a cartoon for it
you have four notes um in this it's a
graph
it's a network the disease starts at
node one
and you toss a coin
and the node one tries to infect node
two at node three
with probability p independently in this
particular case node 3 gets infected
node 2 did not get infected
and let's say in this particular model
node 1 recovers after one time unit
in the next step three tries to infect
two and four
in this case it's successfully infecting
two but unsuccessfully infecting four
uh and it recovers and then two tries to
infect four
is not successful and you can write down
the probability of this event happening
the probability is speed p one three
which is the chance that
one sends a disease on the edge one
three
multiplied by one minus p one two which
is a chance that
you know one was unsuccessful infecting
two and one on and on so you can write
the probability of this particular event
this particular configuration playing
out
right and this is the basic model you
can now
add incubation times and so on so forth
but this is actually an interesting
simple model that can capture a discrete
time process an abstraction of the
problem of
disease spreading now of course the
problem
which i'll come down later and tell you
is
there are issues that come up with this
model too you know it's not like
this is a panacea for for the for the
problems i talked about from for
od based models or mass action models a
way to abstract this out even further
and i think it's a useful way to do it
and that's how we have actually
developed all our
work is to view this as as a graphical
dynamical system
so uh folks here are now hopefully uh
you know well aware of two class of
graphical models that have been used
heavily in computer science literature
one is the graphical models for
inference
which were popularized and have been
very successful in over the last 10
years
and then graphical models of games
what i'm proposing is that you can also
have a graphical model for dynamical
systems
and it's just an abstraction of the
process that i described before
the abstraction says that you instead of
having the simple coin toss and edge you
have a local function on each edge
which tells you how you would change
your state by looking at your own state
and the neighbor state and the function
could be either deterministic
or probabilistic and you can run the
synchronously and you can think of this
as computing a global function which is
obtained by composing these local
functions together
right this abstraction works out very
well you can decide to have as i said a
deterministic local function or
probabilistic one
and that will change the dynamics
what is interesting then is that many
many interesting epidemiological
questions
can be cast as combinatorial problems on
this
graphical dynamical systems and that's
how you do the mapping
hopefully you solve them well and then
have something to say about the policy
back
for instance the question of inference
that and and we just talked to bruno
here in the afternoon
can be clear you know classified in the
setting where you
say that you have observer time series
in this dynamical system and you're
trying to infer
the graph that might have led to this
particular
time series you talk about forecasting
in the falling manner you say that
disease starts from some place and then
you want to understand how the disease
would spread
and what the state of the disease would
be after some time unit
you can talk about interventions in this
which is changing the
properties of the vertices in terms of
functions or edges
to try and control the pandemic or
epidemic right
so the problem is that from a
computational standpoint
uh all this is good but
you're actually trying to reason about
an object that is substantially larger
than the than the representation itself
but in in particular
in this particular setting the phase
space which is the
representation of the possible dynamical
outcomes
is exponentially larger in a in when
your local functions are probabilistic
turns out a good representation of is a
markov chain and people have
interesting algorithms to analyze markov
chain the problem with this
situation is that the markov chain is
exponentially larger than the
representation itself
so that causes sort of computational
difficulties
and i've tried to sort of articulate
this here
the other problem in in this in this
form of modeling
is that well how would you even come up
with a representation of a social
contact network if you want to study
say flu in a city or ebola in in liberia
right so mathematically you have a
network and you have this spread but you
really don't
have any way of measuring this network
in the real world in fact
my i would argue that there's no way
that you can ever get an exact
representation of this network by
endless measurements this is just
impossibility right so you have to
synthesize these networks
the other problem that you face is that
you basically
have actually grown the computational uh
burden on yourself
a huge amount the other models are
relatively simple
these models become extremely hard to to
work with
right so the next hypothesis then is
that our advances in hpc and and data
science can actually
help us solve these problems and and
again
what we've done is we have tried to
build a program called syndemics
which tries to take this representation
theory of networks
combines with hpc simulations uh
with machine learning algorithms and a
way to
synthesize these networks to try and and
address important policy questions i'll
give you a couple of examples of it
here along with it you got to
build a middleware which you can allow
these models to be useful by the end
users
and that's where you come to the third
hypothesis which is
that you know to make this program
successful you
want to be able to push the models
to end users in a rather seamless manner
we had done another project almost 10
years back on urban transport
planning and it was actually very
successful in some ways
but did not find traction in
in the policy world and we learned the
hard way that
we built very cool models at least we
thought were cool models
but really were made to be used by
computer scientists and they had no
interest in becoming computer scientists
and uh from from then on we've learned
that if you want to really
take it to the policy makers or domain
users you've got to really build systems
that they can understand and play with
you know with no
desire to convert them into computer
scientists and i think this is a
message that we have learned the hard
way and i think uh
it's been successful work for us so we
have built out more than
15 apps there's around 12 here that i
can see
but 15 different web apps which allow
users to play with these
backend models that are complicated but
in a way that they don't realize that
these models are being used in this form
right so specifications are clear and
i'll give you some examples of these
models so
i'll start going little faster i realize
that
you know we should stop in about half an
hour or so
so i'll describe this program in five
steps uh
you will construct a a synthetic
population
for a disease and then have a disease
model
uh come up with simulations and then do
analysis and i'll give you examples of
it
i think the hardest part here to begin
with is the construction of the network
and i think it has got
multiple uses beyond epidemics the basic
idea is we want to synthesize
a social contact network to study
epidemics in a city
right so for instance we have actually
synthesized a social contact network to
study flu
in in chicago what does this network
have to go back to our model each node
represents an
individual and what you want is that the
edges between nodes have to reflect the
interaction between
these nodes and the method that we have
used is
is a first principle approach what it
means that is that you use a combination
of
data driven techniques use machine
learning and statistical algorithms
combined with social and behavioral
theories to synthesize it because there
is no way i can
get an exact representation of the
network in chicago
this data you get is you you know
your process is very large it's a really
interesting big data problem the papers
outline why this is the case
just to give you a sense uh you know you
can get
in our case chicago network has over 11
million nodes
and an average degree of 50 and you can
compute the number of edges in this
network
itself so the way we build this network
out
is uh is a series of steps um
using i would say a large number of
different data sets
uh from census to dun and brad street
to data about schools colleges health
units
to data about activity patterns that
people have on a day-to-day basis from
transport planning offices
these data sets are fused together to
build out a
detailed social contact network and this
actually started
with our work back in in in transport
planning
there are new data sets that are
actually making this uh
somewhat easier and i would say
interesting
so barabashi and his group has used
phone records
other groups have done it as well some
folks have started to use
twitter data foursquare was used before
to
sort of map movement patterns which can
be used in this
the key in this network is
twofolds one is that this network is
synthetic
which means if i build a network for
chicago
you cannot identify any person directly
in
in my network at the same time it's
statistically
very similar to the kind of network you
might get in in place like chicago and
how do we measure it
if you take a blog group in chicago and
you look at any census
variable for that block group that would
match the census that you would get for
our
population so it's a synthetic
population uh there's one-to-one
correspondence between people in chicago
and
in our population no direct
mapping but statistically identical
right and we've done a fair amount of
work to try and convince
folks that this is a statistically
accurate representation
i also want to say that this is not
not a program that is going to end
anytime soon as you get more and more
data sets you can improve this
population but what is good about it is
it really is designed
at the get go to preserve privacy and
and
kept keep the anonymity of of the
individuals
the second thing is these networks are
actually dynamic and relational which is
very useful
when we do this modeling that we talked
about so
in this representation we have people on
one side and locations on the other side
people carry a range of attributes all
the attributes that they have
measured in the census surveys age
income
household size gender and on
so on and so forth and the locations
have attributes such as
you know what sort of folks work there
how many people typically are there in
that locations
uh other building codes that go with it
and what do the edges represent they
represent activities so person a might
visit a location
b at a particular time this person might
then go to location c
at between another time and on and on
and now you have a basic structure from
which you can build out a context
network
you can say and you have to make it this
inductive hypothesis saying that if
people for flu for instance
if people are in the same location for a
particular period of time
then i would put a interacting edge
between them and this is a matter of
convention right
if it's a different disease not aerosol
bone disease
the notion of an edge changes this is a
sort of a canonical representation from
which you can derive the interaction
structure based on the disease itself
they're very large this is the numbers
that i have for chicago eight million
odd people when we first made it now
almost ten million plus locations
and edges that are changing in time and
have relational attributes on it
we built a tool called siv it's actually
available on the web
you can you know look at the population
synthesize this way and disaggregate it
and you can
sort of take a look at it will carry all
the information that i've talked about
allows us to explain to uh you know
policy makers
this this aspect of synthetic
information
visualization we then build disease
progression models
we use uh machine learning techniques to
look at data that one gets from limited
experiments
and the data people capture in small
households
and try to assess disease parameters for
within host transmission
we then do simulations of how the
disease would spread uh
through these networks and we have had
to use uh high performance computing
platforms to do it
it has been a challenge over the last
eight years as we have done this to
scale up to uh
to large populations and networks when
we first did this back in 2002
we were studying portland and it was to
take us
24 hours to to get even a single run
together in a meaningful way we can do
this
now much much faster and i've put some
numbers here because i find them
interesting it's a piece of work that
my student and and colleagues have done
about trying to scale this for u.s
the complete u.s 300 million nodes and
approximately 15 billion interactions
on the largest open science hpc machine
we have the blue waters at uiuc
and you can essentially do one run now
or 200 days of epidemic simulation
in about 30 seconds okay
and it you know of course computer
scientists it's fun to do that but i
think from policy standpoint this is
needed because
if you want to do large experimental
designs and counter factual
you really need to make multiple runs so
first thing they are stochastic models
so you need to get multiple replicates
and then if you want to do intervention
analysis you want to actually try
and study many many different cells in
the factorial design to understand this
problem
at this movie which i will try and play
if it plays
where we did a study and it will show
you a spatial spread of the disease
it's a slow-moving disease it takes a
little bit of time
but effectively you will see how this
lights up
we did this study for a senior level
exercise where the disease started in
las cruces mexico
it's the first red block and then it
moves on
because of the folks moving through
people that come in
into the scenario from from mexico in it
work and
and that's how the disease spreads this
particular study was done to
assess the readiness of our rural
health care system you know in terms of
hospital beds in terms of
face mask in terms of ventilators and
what sort of coordination might be
needed
let me give you two or three examples
there are more examples here
of the kind of studies we have done i've
already described all the different
things we've done for ebola
but the other studies we're doing i've
done are actually much
larger in scope and i'll just take two
examples and move to the next
next set of slides the first study of
of node we did was was in fall 2003
when we were asked by the office of
homeland security to study the
potential effects of a small box release
in in in a us city and it turned out
that uh
actually there's a nice paper by larry
wein and his colleagues from stanford
and they'd argued for mass vaccinations
using these uh
mass compartmental models and i think
the results were
uh very interesting and i think made up
made a good point
uh but because the representation
theory itself uh the the argument the
final outcome was that
if you don't do mass vaccinations then
you know not likely to control the
disease very well
we found out using this network model
for portland
that you can actually get away without
doing mass vaccinations
by doing early detection and uh
and followed by a targeted vaccination
strategy and why is this important
turns out that you know people in u.s
are not vaccinated against smallpox it's
eradicated
and the potential likelihood of getting
vaccinia which is a side effect of
this vaccine uh is
is much worse than the the the the
the terror attack itself that might have
happened right so
uh we don't and we don't know that
because we've not really vaccinated
older
people uh you know right now we
usually used to vaccinate kids so so
while vaccinations sound like a good
idea on surface it's actually
has a side effect that might actually be
much larger than the
than the event itself which is which is
something you want to study
uh this paper this is published in in
nature
uh journal in in o4 um
we then did a study for
around the time that h5n1
was something that we're all worried
about and
our group along with two other groups uh
the group led by ireland genius
who used to be then at seattle and uh
and neil ferguson who is at in uh in
imperial college
uh did a study and the interesting part
of the study was three different models
were used
but this concept of targeted lead in
containment was was developed as a part
of this and was outlined in a federal
pandemic influenza plan
which is now used actually to try and
address the the
flu epidemic if it were to happen and it
talks about uh
lead containment okay so yeah
included h3n5 as well as
the most recent things here in
california now is welcome the measles as
well too
right so we've not done measles yet but
we've certainly done
h1n1 after that we're you know just like
ebola we participate in the federal
you know response but it lasted for a
shorter time than the ebola response
and it has actually been each of these
case studies are interesting because
that's where we derive requirements for
our modeling work and the mathematics we
do
and hopefully build better tools for the
next round
we are not prepared for certain class of
diseases in our modeling systems and
i'll say that a little bit
but certainly we are much better
prepared in 2003 right now to do the
studies
each of them finally results in papers
thesis
and mathematical advances that are of
interest
let me quickly tell you about the two
projects i'll start with the forecasting
project this is being done as a part of
a
project that is funded by dtra that
threat reduction agency
and ir pass osi program narendra mi for
it
and the project that we are part of is
called embers
and this is actually a more general
project than just epidemics we're trying
to forecast all sorts of events
elections social unrest
disease outbreaks not just flu but rare
diseases
in focus was to use open source
indicators which means
only open data that is available to
everybody to try and do this forecast
and our focus originally was in latin
america uh this year we moved into
in the middle east uh for for
understanding this this
uh these kind of things this particular
project is interesting because
our team builds causal models
much more so but the other team members
are actually very good at building
data driven models and we have taken
data from all sorts of different places
from google flow trends
search trends weather data places like
table near you know
table near you which tells you about
occupancy of hotels and cancellations
data from a twitter health map which
john brownstein maintains and is a very
successful app
which people have participated in flew
near you there's another app that he
maintains
all these data sets are pulled together
and
we build out a forecasting model for
each of the data sets and then combine
these models
in in a composite way rather than first
combining the data and then building a
composite model and we feel that is a
better scale approach to scale as we get
new newer and newer data sets
so these models are then put together
using a
statistical technique which is motivated
from
topic modeling and is used to generate
forecasts
and it's a live system right now we send
for latin america i think 12 of the
countries there
every week back to irpa and the
forecasts are evaluated
by a gold standard as they call it it's
a data that they've collected
you know ir like darpa wants to have
measurements to decide whether you're
doing well or not
um so this this goes on every week and
this is completely automated there's no
human in the loop right now you can
train the models but you've got to get
this forecast automated completely so
that they get these
event triggers and you're evaluated at
the end of
each each week and told we have also
done ablation tests which tell you how
good each data source is doing
compare this with google fluid trends we
find that our models actually do quite
quite a bit well uh in fact many places
in africa
in in latin america don't even have
google fluids working at least when we
were
doing work there and we can forecast
things like
the count the the date of beginning of
the season
uh when it would end the time of peak
the value at peak
and and uh the scoring is a gpa style
scoring you get a score of
four if you do very very well and
otherwise you get something
smaller it turns out that there are
three teams before
our team did very well in the in the
first two years and as it happens in in
these competitions
one teams move forward so our team has
gone forward for a third year
and we continue this forecast the point
is that
these forecasts are evaluated in a very
rigorous manner
which in itself is an interesting
question how do you
build measurements to decide what
forecasts are good
and i think this is not a solved problem
at all
furthermore i think
that when you do this forecast what you
measure about the
the system is also important and finally
i think is an important point to note
the gold standard we use for this work
is uh
data called paho data it's uh it's a
data that public health authorities
across latin america put together and
produce data sets for each country or
many of the countries in south
in in south america in latin america
but this this power data that is given
to us
only gives you number of cases that uh
that the health authorities have
measured right but there's an
interesting
sort of uh pyramid in in in terms of
what really happens in the
real world so you have a
set of folks x let's say who are
infected
a fraction of them alpha times x
actually
shows symptoms another fraction
beta times alpha times x actually
feels you know sick enough to report
uh that they want to go to the doctor
out of which other factor gamma actually
is detected as having flu
so you know this notion of forecasting
itself is fraught with difficulties
because what we are trying to match is
the final number that paho has given us
uh it might be way off in that
particular setting
than what the real ground truth is and
it's actually an open question
to try and estimate the incidence of flu
in u.s for instance or any other country
based on these measurements themselves
but these hopefully this forecast will
will help us
we started to do this forecast for other
diseases as well chikungunya and dengue
there's a
competition that cdc ran last year we
participate in it
jeff shayman's group from colombia won
the competition
uh for forecasting flu in in us it did
very very well actually
um we're uh
there's a competition that darpa is
running right now for chikungunya i
believe that we are we're a part of
um and i think it's it remains a
question that that is open and will will
be you know continue to be worked on for
years to come we build a app uh just
like the previous apps and i wanted to
give you this example over and over
again
it's called flucaster for flu and
epicaster for other diseases
where just like weather you can actually
go here and see
the incidence of flu and our forecast
and
you can look at the current incidence
rates and
and the numbers as as time goes by okay
you can sort of uh get it down at the
level of a block group
uh uh not block group but a county in
any par you know many regions in u.s and
many other latin american countries
and ebola is included in this as well
now we have another
tool that allows humans
to participate in it it's not exactly
crowdsourcing per se but really humans
become part of this
decision making process a citizen
science scientist
where we show you forecasts and then we
ask you to rank all of them
or modify them slightly so that we can
we can get input from citizen scientists
to gosh
citizen scientist to to show what the
forecast might look like
this allows you to you know collect more
and more information that can then
better inform our models
so i'll go to the last topic and then
i'll stop i'll give an example of the
kind of interventions we do
it's a classic problem i've abstracted
out here because i think it will still
give you a good sense of what the real
problem is
this is a vaccine allocation problem but
you can make a problem on
antiviral allocation too something that
is very basic to intervention analysis
when you look at pharmaceutical
interventions
so let's say you have resources
which is in terms of vaccine this in
this case and
very limited quantities that are
available to you and you want to decide
how to distribute these vaccines
to get the best impact right to control
the disease
it turns out that mathematically this is
a very hard problem
you know to add to it the network
changes
coming up with good strategies is
probably problematic
a lot of papers have been written in
epidemiology and trying to come with
good strategies for allocating vaccines
they're always usually in short supply
for diseases when when they sort of
break out
quickly uh in like h1n1
and others so
what we found out is that by using these
simulations we could come up with
strategies
based on a concept called vulnerability
of a node basically
the idea that you run these simulations
many times see the node that is getting
infected over and over again
use that as an estimator of probability
that that node will be infected
and then use that as a way to allocate
vaccines so you find the node with
highest vulnerability
or chance of getting sick and then
assign these vaccines to these nodes we
found out
doing this empirical analysis that this
actually beats many many
strategies that are you know were
studied in the past
so it was a good news but then here's
the bad news
the problem is i really can't implement
the strategy so it was good news
in terms of writing a paper but really
not an implementation
implementable strategy in the real world
right i cannot measure somebody's
vulnerability in this form
so now we turn the question around as to
how
we can find correlates of this concept
of vulnerability
that we have mathematically abstracted
to a measurable demographic property of
individuals
because that's what you have some chance
of implementing in practice
and we find that the total contact time
turns out to be a good estimator we've
actually compared with cdc strategies
and previous strategies which are
age-based
and found out that they are comparable
or actually do better in many many cases
uh
in terms of reducing the peak and and uh
you know decreasing the the the epidemic
value at peak basically so the the basic
idea here is
that you can use these mathematical
models to come up with
optimal strategies and convert
them using uh data mining tools and
finding surrogates for them in the real
world and i think this basic
concept is actually very general and uh
that's where these tools are likely to
play a bigger and bigger role in the
coming years
and that's where you use uh the the kind
of representations we have
we build out another tool actually this
is rather complicated tool we've taken
three years to build this out
it's called sybil we had a paper in
last kdd we used to call it isis we've
changed the name for obvious reasons
um so and so it's a really interesting
tool it allows epidemiologists to set up
a factorial cell design using a tool
you can choose a population you can
choose the interventions
you can choose the disease models and
you'll get these runs you'll rank order
the interventions
you can do factor analysis and you can
get the
analytics produced by the by the tool
and again you can log on you can get a
guest user account on this
this this particular tool is interesting
because we've been able to do many many
different studies so we've been able to
train many many policy makers now
to use this and it takes about four
hours to train
in a classroom session and they can
start using it and with little bit of
consultation from us
again the idea being that we do not want
to be doing these studies over and over
again
the value of these tools will be best
seen when others start using the tools
the the flucaster and other tools are
actually very simple you don't need any
training it was specifically designed
that everybody can use it
this is little bit more complicated so
it requires a little bit of training
to use it so let me summarize it's uh
close to 5 15 so we can take questions
one is i hope i have convinced you that
public health epidemiology is a complex
systems problem
and that uh controlling and responding
to pandemics
is going to be challenging and that
epidemics the social networks and
behaviors
are all co-evolving at the same time
which makes the problem of coming up
with good solutions that much harder
and very different than typical physical
system
and i think that the advances in big
data and computing
really offer us a qualitatively very
different way to formulate policies
and respond to epidemics than we have
ever done
before ever done before in the past the
tools that we have built out and i
discussed and many others are now
being used by folks on the ground in the
case of ebola
and although they they have their
fits and starts we think that every such
event
helps us refine these tools that
folks who are on the ground
epidemiologists but also
first responders can better use these
tools and try and control epidemics
in the future so i'll stop here and take
questions
uh here are some references uh we did a
tutorial at kdd last year
i put a website it's it's fairly
comprehensive it lasted for four hours
it's got a lot of material there there's
a
article we wrote in cscm with my
colleagues
which gives you an overview of it and
then the web pages that i've described
also contain
a fair bit of information for instance
we have the synthetic network for
liberia sierra leone and uh guinea
placed on our web anybody who is
interested in just network science here
and i
met quite a few people today who are
interested in it can take this as
networks
just like social networks that you have
played with to do analysis
the difference is these networks have
labels on them so the relational and
time varying so you can do other kinds
of analysis that you might not have done
on some other networks that you used to
so thank you very much
i appreciate you listening to this and
i'll take any questions
yes so basically now that your
software is all in whatever shape it's
in
that's a good question if
you know if it starts in a completely
new country we'll have to build out
these synthetic networks for that
country
uh i forgot to mention that we have a
big project underway
where by end of this year we would have
actually built out a synthetic
representation of a large portion of of
the world
once we do that for diseases that we
have seen before flu and ebola
we've done work on mers we've done some
work on producers
would be substantially easier but we get
a new emerging disease
it might take again much more time but i
think we have
we've been able to do much better job
after every round
than in the past so i don't know where
the fixed point of this system is
but hopefully it will take lesser and
lesser time than in the past
ballpark of how many people it takes to
add a new country then
um it's a good question when we first
built
out um it used to take almost a year
with 30 of us to build out
a country of the size of uh you know
with
say 50 million people now it takes much
less time because we've automated that
process
too some of the time it takes is to find
right data sources
there's no clean way that this is this
can be done yet
we are hoping that when we put these
populations out others
will join us in this effort just like
open street maps
project we hope that this will become a
project of the same kind we'll put these
populations out and then people can
contribute data sets
and in fact help us refine some of these
countries better so
i think this is a project that will go
on for a while and we we strongly feel
that it will get better
in in time and we'll start seeing good
results at the end of this year itself
yeah where do you see the big
breakthroughs over the next year too
in terms of cool making either tool
making or
modeling or determining what the
difference is between your mirror world
and the actual world
and how you're modeling that sample
error
right i think a big breakthrough is
going to come through these
you know pervasive apps because
it's going to start allowing us to do
measurements in the field
that we have never been able to do
before behavioral representations
sentiments a lot of epidemic
outbreaks really depend on how people
perceive the disease
so in liberia the cultural practices
were
are such that it was very hard to
control the disease early on but once
people
believed the authorities at some level
this became you know the problem i mean
it's not
in control but it's in under substantial
control than we saw in october which was
raging and numbers are likely to be bad
so i think these apps
are likely to have a large impact in my
opinion the second
place that this is going to help us is
to understand
uh what's called the phylodynamics we
really want to
do this wherein when the disease
starts you can actually start building
vaccines whenever applicable some
disease you know vaccines are not the
right
thing to do but pharmaceutical
interventions have
eventually always helped us control the
disease
and i think they require lead time and
in our case because we started work with
ditra who is responsible for building
vaccines out
these forecasts and and and
and things related to disease are
helpful so the early
earlier information you can get from the
field the better chances you have
uh to give you some sense of flu
vaccines this year for instance the flu
vaccine has been
not very successful and the way it gets
made approximately speaking is that you
collect samples all over the world
you put it in a large sort of bag of mix
possible
strains and then you build a you know a
vaccine around it
so you're constantly collecting data uh
this process of collecting data building
out the
automated facilities on on the medical
side
uh is actually going to have a big
breakthrough and barda is actually
ramping up and building capacity to it
as well
so something will come from biology side
and i think some will come from the
from the modeling side
yeah you're not biologists so you
actually don't care about some of the
things that are coming out have you
tried applying this to
other problems or people trying to other
problems such as computer viruses with
the network topology is completely
different or completely different
problems like
can you stop the next justin bieber
outbreak
now the second one i'm sure i cannot uh
nobody can
the first one is an interesting but yes
i think i take your point
so in general the the methods that i've
outlined are fairly generic
you know they will work with different
networks they will work with different
models of what we'll call a disease to
the extent you call it a disease
uh you know so viruses on computer also
have disease like signatures you know
there's a chance that you can infect
in fact they call it uh you know
use the word epidemics in in that sense
too in fact this nice article called
internet epidemiology that has come out
one of my students just finished his phd
on malware propagation wireless devices
where people can move around and we used
essentially a similar idea there
to understand how you could spread
viruses
and the impact of of these viruses when
you have a
hybrid network where you have a normal
you know wireless network but then
people carry their devices
and you know nowadays these devices can
talk to each other
as you walk by so you can certainly use
it
there's another area though i think that
you might find of
of interest which is non-communicable
diseases so
smoking and obesity are good examples
uh more and more evidence that
you know these are habits in smoking as
a habit
has a lot to do with the social network
itself we still
it's an open debate about the causality
aspect of it but
the social network representation
representation of how
access accessible these these things are
to youngsters and deciding how you might
be able to curtail habits
for smoking might have a significant
impact so i think that's a that's a very
good example obesity is another example
where i think this this can be applied
in the health sciences
you had a question was i was just
wondering um
since you must have analyzed a whole lot
of social contact networks right now
and i was wondering if you found any
common characteristics
to leave in these social contact
networks and if there are particular
characteristics of a social contact
network
that would give grace to a pandemic
i mean a high degree distribution all
right let's say it's a good question
first we find that these are actually
not very well modeled by
typical random simple random graph
models and that's why we started doing
this generative process of building
these networks out bottom up
they have a power loss style degree
distribution in
in some regimes but but
they have other additional structure
which really makes them quite unique so
they seem to follow three or four basic
properties that others have measured
as well so power loss style degree
distributions in many cases
high clustering coefficient in many
cases
they have a fairly high con you know
conductance so in
the it's low diameter and
as a result all these properties make it
very easy
for the disease to spread through fast
and the similar properties are measured
for other networks as well so these are
not the only ones but we do find
interesting differences between say this
kind of
proximity network if i may call versus a
facebook site social network which is
about friends
the degrees there are much much larger
than you know degrees that you get here
because we are talking about
not friendship networks as much but
proximity networks and proximity has to
be defined with respect to a disease
you know smallpox you got to approx you
know in proximal distance of a person
for a very long period before you can
transmit the disease flu maybe not that
long a period
but even with that you know you still
don't get a network with degree to be
that high
usually what would you think about
having a smaller network people
simulating disease spread in a smaller
network what should be the
characteristics of the disease
my general sense is we don't understand
these networks well enough
to use simple random graph models of
that kind
i don't i'm not saying it won't happen
but
the structure in this is is there's a
lot of internal structure to these
networks
we have done uh in a study that might
actually help
explain this a little bit we took this
network and
do a sensitive analysis and one way to
do this
is to try and perturb this network in a
local manner
we find that initially the networks the
epidemic characteristics
are actually of a particular kind but as
you do this perturbation over a long
period of time the network starts
looking like a model
network which is generated by say like
process of
uh simple you know uh matching
of of these of these vertices
but those are epidemic characteristics
are very very different than one
observes in in the real world
so what the structure is is is not clear
it certainly seems to have a recurring
feat
to it which is in terms of diameter
degrees clustering expansion
we do find subtle differences between
say network in one city
with network another city uh initially
we thought if we build out a few cities
that would be
plenty uh we find that no it's it's
quite different the demographics are
very different
so even the structure might be similar
the labels are very different
so portland and seattle is roughly the
same you know seattle and miami sorry
has roughly the same population size
roughly
and it turns out that the epid you know
we did a very detailed study and we got
very similar results in terms of the
epidemics in both places
but the reasons were very very different
one had a
larger family size in in which is in
miami
while the number of kids were much more
in in seattle
for you know per household and on
average and they sort of balanced out to
get similar characteristic at the end
but they really were different networks
to begin with
and i don't think so we understand these
differences we just finished a network
for new delhi
we find again that is a very different
network very densely popular network
we have started representing slums in it
which are a very important component to
it so
so i think these networks are going to
differ right now i think it will take us
some time to figure out these
differences and we're going to put it
out for people to take a look at it
have you thought about adding crazy
variables that you can reliably capture
like payday phase of the moon
cold temperature stuff that is uh just
a kiss on the quad day something yeah
things that would you might not think to
put in but just to see what impact they
might have
no we haven't done it and it's it's a
question that we can we can take up
we also have we have only produced what
we call normative networks on a typical
day right
we haven't produced networks that happen
during a big event a football game for
instance
or a big rally that happens in
washington or seasonal changes you know
washington dc is very different in
summers versus winter there's so many
visitors coming in
so we have really created one template
for a city but there's nothing
that's not it's an abstraction for the
time being
you really want these networks to be a
live object
so that depending on the time of the
year
an event that is happening the disease
you're studying the network will look
different it's really
has to be tailored for the particular
context and we are not there yet we this
is
almost the first first cookie cutter
way much better cookie cutter than a
typical edition like graph or a
parlor like graph but nevertheless still
a
cookie cutter style network that we have
built out i think it will take
years to to refine it and i think you
asked the question of what advances can
be made and i think
as these devices and apps proliferate we
might get
more and more information to improve the
quality of these networks in real time
okay thank you
you